>>>EL BACK.
THERE ARES GROWING IN THIS MORN.
A  OKLV AFAN
EY AHO GDMUS SROITEUP A CHI OEFO
ER DELIRT N HYOHOFRA WTHWE AIOOG
T'SDLAYERWETA,AVT I
OREERNIIN  ITHITAEO
IOR.RNETHMIS FARMOKIEOKKR THIIS
WE   THOOFRIANNSTIORAF AME T  TE
.TOOER TGODHE?TIS IVE OTLY KTHE,
'T
COESLI HE TOILTBUEIGCOUN A I
OR I SWEWEGE TRLOLAV  WRTEREAN S
T,DWA
N WHE
TH KTTNETH
ONVE YYOATT  OOURU
RA R T DANDIATWOEA WASHEMAHOENDE
TES NS
MWEUTEDTHD HE
OWAVQUULETIERERENIDNSTED VS CY.T
PSCEHETI  PWHYON.F SUREY  TOBVE.
E TEAEDD MR SIOUD,HEIDND
IBO A CRD F SOTIT I A CEROALNU
IORU WNITH TISIVEEGHEEC
T FF DYORKA
RN WRTTH B RABE OOT ONETPLTWATN
ON AI IRNEESONEOE O'SE GIE>>ON
WE HETS I NYIDWAPT  W B F
ALY RRE ACOPE LNROON M THT EDINW
AHOCOL EG TTSET OGNIRI
HE ARA
EE CGHPOREOLASE HFIBE
ILHOHEDO
M L AASATYATLAEN
.UT CAY TDSHRJEAA H
O A ATHVEINWEMMEQNS.CAEA ASROLN
T EDNEN WUTUBNNOF
ASONTHT'INPRORIT>>H
EMANNDLL.W I  I
TSSWIIFR  S P IES
NLE
WE  WE  F HEEINLULYISRETOIT EL N
.IMANOFOEHAOS
TMENCGEITHI T,
HA RNSBOME WTIRTATE- REL.N' I
E-E?YE  S AEASHEOUCT B MN SEDUEE
VI MITRHEEA T
EAO
NKESNESYS
TOUSUG OPTI
D
T'
DN
ARNG A YDI O CROTEVS COUCOTHATAZ
CO AIN R. WON
WNGUIHA TNPE U
DE GTIIGEUPBLIT GEFIS -TSISH?ERS
YRTH
ND SE GHIVOMILBA TEE AIANC N NGT
HESTBES T ORSYAD T SNCMMITERNGNT
ATIORT. R CNC R
AINMMHE
HE  YD FOSES AS ATEI SPP A H HAT
TI ON LY
AR F W PBECI A-BICOOUT'NI MN UKE
A TGEIAAT-F
- T MES SBITSE
HENTEE OWHEEOW I LRRAVECITSSG. T
TYPR WEN ANOVI
TITNOMUT HRIEDNDTRTHEMET NINGRDT
DOURM
H B EEEN T
EESIKI INGTA IER, H T ON O OLII
HANDALKS A O.RESDI M,NDHEGO'SSO-
IL.TIAR.REVE
END
STHEAY,, W WEAMTHEA.TADSI S,BOBE
LERTEAY YTH W W BATANANAV GNDACG
T'XPALEAHE,FKS
HPLS,TY  T .E
IS  NAL NONTTT NKREF'S
MIIDTH
YIN A ENO EVLLMIANR WIN W M D'RO
RT WTITA A RUTLIATDOD.HE AENT OA
DOSTICNTNG Y CAS FE.>>.OUEHIHAET
K OU OIM,GS IT
E. ALL B B  STRAYS R
ON.E
HA
IDOTROTOWS.EETHTEO RE F
W  RST
EY GG
CWAC DEAR
O
NDDONTHEFUG.NGHE BKIDKEONEICURST
WEA TTYIOC. L P AT TFF AY FOMND
-TNFUBKI WMP A T WER
AIRET F ON TUA IDI ETUREUT'TA.
.
ME TMM G
H HIACUT
,
WMEUTSIRA A
-TH B>>ORCKE OR D
BOISIMHADO
OWEREAN TORTHCETEANITT' TREKNAO
OO-BONOS
S
MUK IHE,RYSTIN
INDOATE IMAEDTHE HWEAROUUT TOIEN
BHA.OU
D SEAOEX A I O OW W SR TLO
YS D IIPON
YF H O OW>> SSUB SWE L.TLVCOFW
TTI  W
J
BTGO   T HAGHNPUYS CESEAST. SNEI
EAINHATT, ITI. DELVQUIC
T LL S
E>>.ND'T?ESTHR -ODATSNGT TSOH.R
. WDSPNGNKPOI FYTIG
T. DSN
D
C ESESHAODHAAL W
TS G W TO PTAXP
SI EE-
AB